sometimes
you got to work a little
so you can ball a lot
that was beautiful
that changed me
i'll give you 10 minutes
i like to know who i'm in business with
i want to meet your boy what up big t
stop
this must be the lovely donna ashante
listen beautiful let's cut the bowl
right you want this i definitely want
this t.h wants this
let's seal this devil's three-way right
here right now step one we buy into this
club step two we roll over to the club
either in your mercedes-benz or my
pre-owned acura legend step three i
dagger you on the dance floor just
bounce bounce bounce back so now all the
ladies saying bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce
what do you say sexy
i'm out why i hate that guy
welcome to paradise my man you can chill
over there by the bar we also got
basketball at any time you want with roy
hibbert and debt less shrimp oh my god
that's an actual nba player he plays for
the pacers nba is on strike so we got
him for only like 75 of his original nba
salary what up roy this is all you want
me to do play one-on-one with deadlift
yes and keep your mouth shut
jean-ralphio take me there
[Music]
who are you this is ben he's here to
help us with the paperwork ben is that
your real name yes oh you could do
better than that i'ma help you out right
now your name is angelo angelo thank you
so much for coming out get a thicker tie
it looks weird on you makes your head
look like a fish secondly i don't know
where the paperwork is but when you find
it can you take care of it for us we
don't have any pens because we're afraid
it's gonna leak in our shirts lastly i
hate the name angela i'm gonna switch it
up for you right now your new nickname
is
jello shots what do you think about that
j-shot do we have questions yeah where
are we
all right ben if you need anything one
of these models that we pay to hang
around here we'll grab it for you
meantime we're gonna be playing video
games tweeting our high scores
hit it hey look who it is hey
tom jean ralphio
professional basketball players what's
up jell-o shot can i ask you guys a
question
how exactly are you making money you
want to know how we make money do you
want to know how we make money by
literally printing our own money we
bought a printing press this prints
bills with our faces and the e720 logo
on them
we promote the company by going to clubs
and tossing the bills in the air and
screaming free money okay you can't just
print your own money uh this past you
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
so it looks like we each end up with
about 5 000 a piece
stop we got five g's each that's amazing
you started out with 450 000
entertainment 720 is dead it's up in
company heaven along with pets.com
blockbuster and ask jeeves
my company's no better than a company
where you ask a fake butler to google
things for you
so what's next tommy davidson
i say we invest our 10 large and then i
accidentally get run over by a city bus
and we start our own hip hop label
we have this place for one more night
right we're outta tomorrow at noon
what if we took
every dime we had left
through one last party made it the
essence of everything we wanted the
company to be a party
for the end of the world you had me at
every time we have left because i'm in
like laura flynn boil from the practice
swag
[Music]
welcome to e720s and in the world
celebration the entire party's a vip
area there's also a double v up here a
triple vip area and the centurion club
elite vip area sponsored by sobe
lifewater no one's a lot in there not
even us
we also hired ten huge scary bouncers
with earpieces what up keith
he actually once tossed me out of a club
three years ago water under the bridge
dj blunts is mixing up some new beats
ballers and ballarats fasten your seat
belts the perfect party begins clink
now
oh thank god
no one shows up to a good party on time
if anyone had actually showed up right
now the whole party would have been
ruined would have been a disaster i
don't want a lap party
what's up what's up are you guys having
a good time tonight
i think we gotta take things to the next
level
okay
you guys pretend you're ron swanson and
you're trying to decide whether you want
to invest in this company be
super critical you're short
and here we
go
tom haverford and john raphael
strappersgene creators of entertainment
720 proudly present
read the swag
parents are you tired of watching your
middle school-aged children grow out of
the nice clothes you buy for them
then rent them from rent to swag i own
it you rent it you wear it
you clean it you return it i get rich
redness wax whoa
please there's actually a lot more but
tell us your thoughts so far it's the
greatest thing i've ever seen in my
entire life
it's terrible it's terrible you guys i
love you babe you're so smart you're
presenting this to ron swanson don't
talk about any of your old failed
businesses get rid of that stupid light
show and definitely don't use any weird
made up words that ron doesn't
understand but the presentation's
tomorrow at 8 am we don't have time to
start from scratch well
if you do any of that he's not gonna
invest so
your funeral
tommy t you just missed the craziest of
crazies clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed hiding
in a dumpster coming here crashing on
your couch for a week cause technically
i'm homeless hey moustache i'm gonna hit
the couch you know i'll be
tom who is this
person this is mona lisa saperstein my
new sales associate mona lisa saperstein
does that mean oh yeah
she's my sister my twin sister from the
same mystery thank you so much for
hiring mona lisa it means so much to me
even though honestly she's the worst she
is the worst person in the world huge
skank terrible but thank you it means a
lot of course gotta keep it in the
family yeah but does it have to be this
family actually that reminds me
boss man i need to leave early today
because my shrink got me and him tickets
to a pitbull concert
and i already committed to that and so
if you say that i can't go it's like
you're taking something away from me
um store's really busy i kind of need
you to stay i totally hear you um i also
don't like what you're saying so if you
say no i will start a fire in the
bathroom
okay i guess you can go yeah i know i
can
what did i tell you huh
the words
she's the worst in the world john
ralphio how are you hold up my dad said
that yeah john ralphio he told me
that i had screwed you out of my
business
so he was gonna screw me back any idea
why he'd believe such a thing that is so
weird
that is so uh you know what honestly not
i'm thinking about it this may be it i
actually told him that rent-a-swag was
my idea and that you had stole it from
me why would you say that because my dad
is always riding me for never having a
job and i just didn't want to show that
i blew it again
oh
and i don't know if this is relevant but
i told him that you made me sign up for
a bunch of credit cards and then max
them out by buying illegal white jaguar
fur coat oh
that's probably not relevant that's not
relevant though i don't know
all that's lying about me stops now
this is my life please one of you has to
tell him the truth got it oh you got me
oh okay fine you know what
i'm gonna do the unthinkable
i'm gonna have a short honest
conversation with my father thank you
you